hey there welcome to three blue one
brown so I make videos that animate math
for a lot of them I just try to find
something kind of interesting or
thought-provoking not necessarily in the
typical progression of subjects that a
student would see in school to see what
I mean there check out some of the
recommended playlists some of the
channel though is more directly targeted
at people actually trying to learn a
commonly taught subject for an example
of what I mean there check out the
essence of linear algebra series that I
did I'll always be working on some other
essence of series like this so stay
posted for more now when I say that
these videos animate math on the one
hand I mean that very directly things
are explained with moving visuals and
anthropomorphic kinda cartoonish pie
creatures but my hope here is that they
animate math in another more literal
sense of giving life to the subject math
kind of gets a bad rap for being
abstruse and inhuman and let's face it a
lot of it is symbol heavy and can be
introduced in a pretty unmotivated way
but the fact is good math is nothing
less than art I'm guessing a lot of you
out there know that feeling when you
wrap your mind around a really clever
argument and it's got that very unique
flavor of satisfaction and same goes for
re understanding something familiar but
in a novel or unexpected light here I'm
just trying to do my part to share
feelings like those with more people so
take a look at some of the videos here
and if you want to stay posted about new
stuff or to just see new videos rather
than this trailer whenever you come back
to the page consider subscribing
you